träger warnung in diesem video geht es
um psychische erkrankungen und
suizidgedanken
ja ich glaube meine kasse will immer
dass ich nicht am baum sehen als dass
ich bei ihnen eine therapie machen kann
also seit mitte märz letzten jahres
warte ich darauf dass ich heute irgendwo
ein therapieplatz und ich habe mich
irgendwie schuldig gefühlt so dass ich
mir da jetzt dass ich da ist noch raum
betteln muss dass sich das bezahlt
kriegen obwohl ich immer krankenkassen
beiträge bezahlt habe bei der suche nach
einem psychotherapie platz gibt es oft
würden die man überwinden muss ich habe
mit vielen betroffenen gesprochen die
mir erzählt haben was ihnen passiert ist
manche sind in diesem video zu erkennen
andere wollen anonym bleiben weil sie
nachteile fürchten
zum beispiel im job immer dieser gedanke
euro krise bekommt es vielleicht immer
mit mir hat jemand schneller hilfe suche
so bleibt dann vielleicht als chance
angesehen
durch alle mit denen ich gesprochen habe
haben eins gemeinsam und zwar eine
verzweifelte suche ich blicke in diesem
video auf drei hürden die es dabei immer
wieder gibt und zwar das gefühl der
scham dass man überhaupt hilfe braucht
dann zu langes warten auf einen
therapieplatz und probleme bei der
kostenübernahme durch die krankenkasse
[Musik]
mir ist ganz wichtig am anfang zu sagen
wir schauen in diesem video auf die
probleme im bereich der psychotherapie
in deutschland vielen menschen wird
geholfen aber es gibt eben auch
schwierigkeiten und da wollen wir in
diesem video drauf schauen also lasst
euch bitte nicht entmutigen wenn ihr in
diesem video hörten schwierig ist sein
kann therapeutische hilfe zu bekommen
sondern bleibt der bitte dran
grundsätzliche tipps dafür habe ich auch
später im video und unten in der
beschreibung
am anfang jeder erkrankung steht
erstmalig muss merken dass irgendwas
nicht stimmt und ich hilfe brauche und
dann muss ich mich aber auch trauen nach
hilfe zu fragen
und das ist nicht immer so einfach ja
man hat halt ein bisschen die sorge so
abgestempelt werden so als ich meine
jetzt irgendwie kaputt oder minderwertig
oder jetzt ist so verrückt geworden und
man hat das schon so ein bisschen angst
dass man ausgegrenzt oder schief
angeguckt wird man wird also wegen einer
psychischen erkrankung stigmatisiert
darüber habe es mit dr margraf
gesprochen er ist psychotherapeut und
psychiater und beschäftigt sich mit
stigmatisierung dadurch dass er
stigmatisiert wird oder allein schon
dadurch dass er befürchtet stigmatisiert
werden zu können entsteht ein innerer
stress das ist auch verständlich denn
der mensch ist ja ein soziales wesen er
ist auf soziale kontakte angewiesen und
wenn man ausgegrenzt wird
dann macht das eben stress darüber
hinaus gibt es das phänomen der selbst
stigmatisierung das heißt die
betroffenen nehmen die negativen
ansichten die die bevölkerung über sie
hat quasi an und glauben schon selber
daran dass man ihnen nicht helfen kann
dass sie vielleicht selbst schuld sind
und diese chance ist extrem schlimm als
es macht mir ganz großen teil auch
dieser krankheit aus und diese charme
sorgt auch dafür dass du durch den
abwärts spielern beliebt dass du dir
vielleicht auch keine hilfe mehr suchst
und irgendwann wird es schon sprung dann
kommst
mit niemandem jedoch übersehen sie
sollen daran ist dass die irgendwie
darüber zu bilden oder auch wieder 10
uhr
aber das spielt nicht nur der patient
oder die patientin eine rolle sondern
natürlich auch die gesellschaft selbst
und in deutschland sind psychische
erkrankungen nach wie vor stigmatisiert
das bild das die gesellschaft von
psychischen krankheiten in deutschland
hat ist oftmals negativ und dazu auch
noch oftmals falsch und verzerrt
schizophrene patienten oder solche mit
drogenabhängigkeit werden oftmals als
gewalttätig unkontrolliert und
gefährlicher eingeschätzt
andere patientengruppen wie menschen mit
depressionen oder burnout oder auch
alkoholabhängigkeit werden als
willensschwach eingeschätzt oder auch
nicht leistungsfähig als nicht
leistungsfähig zu gelten das befürchtet
zum beispiel max er will hier angenommen
bleiben weil er nämlich lehrer werden
wollen
und er hofft auf eine verbeamtung und
wenn er eine therapie macht ist nicht
ganz klar ob er wirklich verbeamtet wird
hat mich dann schlussendlich dazu
entschlossen in diesem bild nichts zu
geben also nicht so viele anzutreten
angst dass meine berufliche zukunft
einfach darunter wald und das ist nicht
wenig verbeamtet werden weil man eine
psychotherapie gemacht hat das beruht
auf den beamtenstatusgesetz und darin
heißt es ernennungen sind nach eignung
befähigung und fachlicher leistung
vorzunehmen und ob man mit einer
psychischen krankheit geeignet genug ist
das ist ermessenssache
wenn man das gefühl der scham dann
überwunden hat kommt der eigentliche
erste schritt einen therapeuten oder
eine therapeutin finden um einen termin
auszumachen kann ein patient eine
therapeutin oder einen therapeuten
anrufen oder eine mail schreiben
am besten wird jeder versuch jemanden zu
finden aufgeschrieben warum er gleich
gleich
ich hab lorin schweizer franken
angehoben und andere 1 belegt ist vier
bis sechs monate ich weiß also die
ersten das erste telefonat das war
wirklich die haben mich so im satz schon
unterbrochen und haben gesagt ja wir
keine plätze mehr frei
meistens war die information in ihrem
gang auch nicht auf die banken ist
manchmal melden sie sich in sechs
monaten noch war es auch so ruhig denn
wirklich versucht hat irgendwie vier
wochen hintereinander sprechzeit
anzurufen und ihnen keinen raum also gar
nicht so einfach
und es gibt noch eine möglichkeit und
zwar die tendence servicestellen der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung zu
erreichen unter der 11 6 11 gegen die
vermitteln innerhalb von vier wochen
eine erste sprechstunde bei einem
therapeuten oder einer therapeutin mit
kassen sitzen das klingt eigentlich ganz
gut aber diese therapeuten und
therapeuten sind dazu verpflichtet erst
gespräche anzubieten
oftmals haben sie gar keine kapazitäten
die erkrankte person auch für eine
therapie aufzunehmen das heißt dann
wieder zurück zur termin service stelle
und alles geht wieder von vorne los dass
das alles so schwierig ist habe ich mit
beatrice munz von der bundes therapeuten
kann man gesprochen warum ist es denn so
schwierig für manche einen therapieplatz
zu bekommen
die schwierigkeit beruht hauptsächlich
darin dass es in der versorgung für
psychisch kranke menschen zu wenig
psychotherapeutinnen und
psychotherapeuten gibt die mit den
krankenkassen abrechnen dürfen
ich betone das deshalb weil es nicht zu
wenig kolleginnen und kollegen gibt
sondern es gibt zu wenige kolleginnen
und kollegen die im kassenärztlichen
system zugelassen sind
also es gibt zu wenige therapeuten und
hab heute mit kassen sind also solche
die direkt bei der kranken
abrechnen können und dagegen wird wohl
seit jahren auch zu wenig getan und es
gab wohl von anfang an zu wenige solcher
kassen sitze 1999 wurde die anzahl an
psychotherapeutischen kassen sitzen
festgelegt und dann hat sich damals
daran orientiert wie viele therapeuten
und therapeuten schon im ambulanten
bereich arbeiten durften
und das waren damals schon zu wenige
also wir schleppen im grunde genommen
von anfang an die letzten mittlerweile
21 jahre ein erhebliches start defizit
mit was bis heute nicht ausgeglichen
wurde wir reden also immer diese anfangs
defizit ja her es wurde zwar immer
wieder nachgerüstet aber wohin
ausreichend zuletzt gab es 2009 10 neue
kasten setzte in der psychotherapie und
zwar 800 aber vorher hatte ein gutachten
festgestellt dass eigentlich 2413 neue
kassen sitzen psychotherapie notwendig
wären die folge die patientinnen und
patienten haben lange wartezeiten
aber was tun wenn man lange warten muss
und kein therapie platz bekommt eine
lösung kann eine therapie seien bei
einem therapeuten oder einer therapeutin
ohne kassen sitzt im sozialgesetzbuch
heißt es konnte die krankenkasse eine
unaufschiebbare leistung nicht
rechtzeitig erbringen und sind dadurch
versicherten für die selbst beschaffte
leistung kosten entstanden sind diese
von der krankenkasse in der entstandenen
höhe zu erstatten
soweit die leistungen notwendig war
bedeutet im fall der psychotherapie der
patient oder die patientin kann
beantragen dass die kosten für einen
privaten therapeuten oder therapeuten
von der krankenkasse übernommen werden
wie das geht der patient oder die
patientin muss nachweisen dass es anders
nicht geht
dafür muss dokumentiert werden dass man
bei ungefähr fünf behandlern erfolglos
nach einem therapieplatz gefragt hat
dann braucht man noch eine bescheinigung
eines therapeuten mit kassenzulassung
dass eine therapie wirklich dringend ist
die gibt es zum beispiel im erstgespräch
und natürlich braucht man einen privaten
therapeuten der
therapieplatz frei hat ziemlich viel
bürokratie und aufwand für jemanden der
psychisch erkrankt ist
man könnte sagen wenn es zu wenige
plätze gibt dann ist das wenigstens eine
möglichkeit aber dieser antrag auf
kostenübernahme wird nicht immer
bewilligt und auch mit begründungen
abgelehnten nicht immer nachvollziehbar
sind
wir liegen mehrere solche ablehnung vor
zum beispiel kosten für eine
psychotherapie dürfen wir nur übernehmen
wenn die therapeutin beziehungsweise der
therapeut eine kassenzulassung hat und
das stimmt ja einfach nicht wir haben
einige in gesprächen und nachrichten von
solchen ablehnungen erzählt ich möchte
nur sagen dass ich erstmal auch noch
gerne positiv war also dass ich erst mal
noch irgendwie so eine chance nicht
sicher aber schon die erwartung hatte so
hätte dann schon zustimmen weil ich
dachte ich hätte alles gemacht ich hab
das ja ich habe mich bemüht und
[Musik]
ablehnung war es dann halt auch so dass
das ist bei mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
schlechter wurden defekte eigentlich
schlechter wurde
ja was dann tatsächlich eher so dass es
nicht so schlecht ging dass ich wirklich
ziemlich konkret gedanken hatte
vorbereitung schon getroffen hatte
dass ich dann eher so ein scheiß drauf
bin doch eh nichts spenden
lara ist dann in eine klinik gegangen
und heute geht es ihr gut
solche ablehnungen die nicht
gerechtfertigt sind sind natürlich
schwierig zu verdauen
wolf sind diese ablehnung dann schlagen
so in die gleiche kerbe also in die
kabel von nicht verdient es mir gut geht
gerade bei diesen komplex
traumatisierten menschen erlebe ich das
immer wieder dass das vorhandene wäre
flüssigkeit erleben und nochmals ja noch
vielleicht aktualisiert wieder kann man
vielleicht sagen ach ich hab das nicht
verdient dass es mir gut geht ich habe
unterstützung ich verdient ich muss muss
weiter alleine klarkommen
in meinen gesprächen wurden mehrere
krankenkassen genannt die
kostenübernahme immer wieder abgelehnt
haben ohne dass es nachvollziehbar war
die krankenkasse die mir am häufigsten
genannt wurde war die obama ich habe sie
mit ausreichend vorlauf kontaktiert und
um ein kurzes gespräch gebeten aber die
obama wollte mir aus kapazitätsgründen
kein interview zur psychotherapie
platzsuche gegen stigmatisierung lange
wartezeiten und probleme bei der
kostenübernahme
das sind alles schwierigkeiten im
bereich der psychischen erkrankungen die
schon längere zeit bestehen aber die
problematik wird jetzt gerade in kouvola
zeiten noch mal deutlicher laut einer
umfrage der deutschen
psychotherapeutenvereinigung gab es im
januar 2021 40 prozent mehr anfragen in
psychotherapeutischen praxen als 2020
wochen ohne konnte ich noch konnte ich
jedem der den konnte ich sagen wenn wir
die kostenübernahme durch haben dann
habe ich einen platz für sie und seit
der pandemie kann ich das nicht mehr zu
haben
ich bin absolut falsch kann dieses jahr
keinen mehr aufnehmen
und ich muss jeden tag mindestens drei
leuten sagen tut mir leid ich hab ihm
platz und es musste ich war vor nicht
[Musik]
wie geht es euch mit dem thema
psychotherapien habe die erfahrung in
dem bereich alles gut geklappt hat
schlecht geklappt schreibt uns in die
kommentare